snowballs over time
and and
takes unexpected turns and pays off in
surprising and unexpected ways and i
i've had a lot of people just kind of
show up on zoom or
you know linkedin or facebook saying hey
i read your book can you think about
doing this project there's been a lot of
great and interesting opportunities for
me but so yeah you're building all kinds
of sweat equity now that will pay off
for you in ways that you can't imagine
something wow that's good to know
yeah yeah i really appreciate you saying
that sometimes when you're so close to
it it's like
you're just like what am i doing
tell my wife
yeah yeah that's
yeah that's what i'm like
i'm getting rich a dollar at a time i'm
well on my way
yeah it's like telling my wife you know
it's honey we're helping a lot of people
and there's a really engaged community
she's like oh does georgia power accept
community is that what
you know what i mean so but i i mean i
just try to you know focus on gratitude
and understand the yeah like the long
term
[Music]
she already made that mistake when she
signed on
any objection
oh
we signed yep she signed the uh the
lease or the what in the least this is
yeah
[Laughter]
let me see
yeah let me um
see what um
what um i can get going here
because i'm trying something new with
live streaming to multiple
places so we're gonna see if this works
um
so let me see here
one moment
[Music]
all right
i think let me see here
hmm
i think we may be live
are we live
i think we're live
oh i think i think it is working yeah
i heard yeah i heard that echo i think
it looks kind of
grainy i i see john i tried to get fancy
and stream to multiple places
and it seems like it's going to more
places but it looks like
you go to seven different areas and then
it takes
a seventh of what
i don't know what i'm talking about
basically i don't think the video
quality is great yeah
the bandwidth
yeah so
we'll see what the people people are
commenting
they're saying um
let me see
let me go back this is a great start
this is a good start
isn't
it we like to hit the ground running
here if i hit the ground running we mean
hit the ground with our chin
[Laughter]
so this will just look like we're on a
um
we're on dial up that's all so it'll be
totally fine
but we do have people um
mike marr
said i'm here
uh ben webb said uh jones said hi all
bob said hi all mike maher is here
ben webb ready to rock a wednesday
evening let's do this
um anthony
says hi joel and john
stargate121 says i'm here
david geary you are alive dennis says
oh you know david
david was a
writer i worked with in new zealand in
1993 and 1994 god help us what god help
us all
you know joel you and i were talking
about about this before we started that
you don't know what's going to wash up
on your page and you really don't know
when you're young
how much
lies ahead of you and i'm just thinking
about david geary we're friends we
exchange emails from time to time and
obviously he got the blast that i sent
out about today's workshop but i like to
feel like we passed a point in time
together a generation ago and it was a
meaningful enough experience for us both
that we're still in each other's lives
what more can you ask for really that's
beautiful david good to see you here i'm
not seeing any chat on my end uh
yeah this is on uh this will be on
youtube oh he says he can barely
says your sound is really low let me see
if i can i think
i think that's on me though hold on let
me try to um talk real quick i'm moving
the microphone closer to my mouth
check one two check 3 4 6 12.
yeah let's see if um
and dennis says we'll see how they if
that made it better
um see see what happens i
i tried to get fancy for john
and then
that's what happened what's that thing
that goes before it before
oh yeah pride
before fall
now i'm i'm making the same mistake
you're making because i just went to the
youtube feed
to uh oh now i can see the uh i can see
the comments oh yeah
oh
they said i have uh dennis has a book
from john here in germany crazy
a man who looks like him in your show
cool here's a book from you in germany
cool uh yeah i have i have a book in
german the comic toolbox in german if
you can believe that
[Laughter]
the joke that i tell on that the first
time i went to teach comedy writing in
germany you know i come from los angeles
from hollywood
i went to germany and i sat down in a
room full of writers and i said hey guys
you know i told all my friends in los
angeles that i was going to germany to
teach comedy writing and they all
thought that was pretty funny the class
laughed they had a good spirit about it
but this one guy's leading sport he puts
his hands on the table he says this
friends of yours tell us their names
uh born brandon said i got your new book
thanks for signing it
oh good deal nice
what thanks
um i i think it's still low so what i'm
gonna do is um
i'm gonna reset i'm gonna do another
um
i'm gonna do another
live stream and we'll just do it to the
youtube channel
we tried y'all we tried so just stay on
the youtube channel and you'll see
another video come up in literally like
10 10 seconds so we'll be right back
oh
we did it
all right we should about back live you
know it was worth a shot to to be like
we gotta spread this to the internets
but this is how this is how we learn
kids
it's worth a shot
there we go yeah the video looks a lot
better
as well
oh cool so i think
oh cool okay so i think people that were
on the youtube still see it so let's see
how the sound is for people now
can you all hear us oh i'm sorry i'm
sorry
i was listening for the sound and then i
realized i was at least half responsible
for the sound so
check one two check can you hear me now
that's always a good joke are you fake
mike
ooh anthony said much better good better
sound is great okay
we did it johnny all right
we did it well let's get this
let's get this party started perfect all
right so thank you all for hanging out
um
those of you that are watching on
facebook or any other place um please
just come to our youtube channel
iv to youtube but
what we're gonna do here
is a live q a with john here and he
actually um he just released a new book
and i someone just said you had signed
them a book i think born branded and um
john also sent me a book and he signed
it as well which was very generous and
i'm so grateful for that
so um you've been on the show before
but
just to jump into it here
with this book like
i thoroughly enjoyed it as a comedian 12
years in the game i learned a lot but
what
what with you writing this what are you
hoping that comedians
leave this book with
well that's a great question first of
all let me explain where my authority
comes from more than 30 years of
experience in teaching and writing
comedy and less than 10 minutes
experiencing stand-up comedy i want to
make that clear that i went into the
book as an avid amateur but i've been
doing this all my life if there's ever
something i want to learn how to do i
find someone to pay me to teach it which
is unfortunate if the subject is archery
or sailing both of which i taught
without knowing the first thing about it
but like i wrote 10 books on poker and i
was never a good poker player so i'm
kind of a poster child for the concept
of those who can't do teach that's my
brand that's where i live
but um in terms of what people expect to
get out of it i'm underselling obviously
but um
the three things that i focus on in this
book are tools inspiration and awareness
and these three things really go
together because you have good tools if
you have strategies you know what you're
doing then you can operate with more
confidence you can get better results if
you're getting better results you're
going to feel better about yourself
more in touch with yourself
with goals
and more inspired and excited by what
you're doing so i'm trying to create a
virtuous circle for people where they
can add skills
add awareness and use the skills and
awareness to level up their inspiration
and then ride that inspiration like a
wave they can surf so that's what i'm
about
and and i would like to say so far so
good people are responding quite
positively to the book it's it's uh um
what's the one liner i use it's already
broken through in the amazon top 10
digits so that's good
and then digits
it's right up there
in the in the millions of stuff
and uh but but people are responding
positively to it i feel like
this is a book that is finding the
audience that it's intended to find
which is people who are somewhere on the
path toward stand-up comedy excellence
not necessarily as far along as they
want to be but emotionally intelligent
enough to know that emotional
intelligence matters and they think that
if
you're in the audience and you're you're
listening to this and you're asking
yourself do i care about emotional
intelligence if the answer to that
question is yes i think you're going to
find a warm and
compatible home in this book
for sure yeah and it almost like what
was interesting and mike maher actually
said this should be required reading for
hot breath
um
and i mean i and i agree i mean it's a
it's a shorter book as well which i
think comics can uh you know appreciate
as well it like but there's so much
information in here and what i what i
picked up on and reading it it's
there's a lot of like technique in here
but it's also it almost is like a
self-help book in a lot of ways as well
there's a lot of things about mindset
and self-awareness and goal setting that
i think as comedians
we get so stuck in
i gotta write and perform i gotta write
and perform i gotta write and perform i
gotta write and perform and you can kind
of get stuck in that cycle
and forget to
have a purpose behind what you're doing
to have a reason to have a goal to have
a vision
for
who you want to entertain and how you
want to come off to them like those are
those are some like of the minutia
of becoming a professional comedian that
probably took me
eight to ten years to really start
honing in on and if this is something
people can do early on it's going to
make their whole career that much easier
what you're talking about is having a
practice okay in this case we're talking
about having a practice of stand-up
comedy but you can have a practice of
anything art music business
medicine anything at all but if you
think about it as
i have a goal i have to achieve my goal
and if i don't achieve my goal i die and
then that's a no-win situation you're
never going to
achieve the end result that you think is
there it's like dangling in the sky
somewhere and you're just never going to
catch up to it but if you change your
goal too i'm here to have a practice and
improve my practice something you can
never fail at because you can always get
better at your practice just by putting
in more time and you get that relaxed
feeling that today's outcomes are
important because i want to do them well
i want to write good jokes i want to
perform well but today's outcomes aren't
really that important because even if i
don't get the outcomes i'm looking for
i'm still adding to my storehouse of
self-knowledge and tool craft i'm
building in my practice so the minute
you say to yourself i'm in my practice
it's like turning on a light you never
have to wonder if you're in the right
place or not you know you're in the
right place because you're in your
practice and it's where you want to be
it's funny i was having a
chat on facebook earlier today about
well you know why do you do what you do
is it just habit is it an itch that you
can't help but scratch i think for a lot
of people in stand-up it's i don't know
i'm just compelled i got to get up on
stage maybe people realize that it's the
buzz you know they they like the
validation
and they like that feeling they get when
a joke lands
but you can lose perspective
and get into get to the point where
you're just chasing the buzz without
asking what brought you to it in the
first place and here's what i think if
you look at yourself honestly
you're going to say i came to this for a
reason and the reason was there was
something about myself or my experience
that i wanted to express and maybe along
the way i got distracted in that because
i realized oh you got to write a tight
five you got to talk to the bookers and
you got to do this you got to be that
and you got to fist bump the host and
call out the host and you know all of
this protocol which is part of it it's
being in community and it's important
but what lit the fire in the first place
never forget what lit the fire in the
first place because that's what sustains
you
it's not the gigs it's not even the left
that's it's a good buzz but it's a
secondary drug one might say the primary
buzz is the sense of fulfillment that
comes from recognizing that you are
turning your human experience into
communication that's meaningful to other
people yeah
yeah and i think that growth mindset is
so
important especially as a comedian in
the highs and lows that come with it and
a big part of
you mention in the book is like not
taking things personally like when you
bomb it's not you reframe it as like
what can i learn from this and not like
what's wrong with me like those little
mindset shifts can really take the the
grueling grind of being a comedian and
make it more fun and fulfilling
wow i i cut my teeth on situation comedy
in hollywood in the 80s and 90s and and
i was not emotionally prepared for what
i went through and a lot of what
informed my career had to do with how i
was not prepared i didn't have the the
basis of self-awareness and fundamental
sense of self and security that i needed
i had a lot of insecurity that i was
dealing with in processing and i look
back on those times and i say i had to
figure out so much of this stuff on my
own i mean i had good mentors but nobody
ever came along and said outcomes don't
matter
you know
making them love you doesn't matter
validation comes from within i really
wish that i had that kind of
voice inside my head when i needed it
and so if you're asking what i'm about
now i'm at the other end of my life i'm
66 years old so i really am speaking to
not just my former self but people who
are now the age that i was then
if i can save them some of the heartache
that i went through i'll really feel
like i have been in service
and that's part of what i'm about being
in service
i totally agree i mean probably it took
me probably eight years into my 12-year
career to start focusing on what i can
control and not seeking that outside
validation of oh i want to get on that
show with the cool flyer or like why is
so and so getting such and such that i'm
not even though
i'm not actively even pursuing it i just
deserve it because i'm the chosen one
like all these stories i was telling
myself like it it just held me back and
when i started focusing on what i can
control
and creating my own opportunities that's
when people actually started bringing
opportunities to me
perhaps you're reflecting on a quality
that i know i have and that is a sense
of arrogant insecurity what you kind of
describe as
i kind of describe on one hand dude you
should totally buy my book and on the
other hand i'm sorry i killed the tree
you know it's it's like i can't help
thank you
i can't help i can't help feeling
extremely good and extremely bad about
myself at the same time and i think
that's a very common thread for people
in all creative practice
so
a lifetime ago even a generation ago
even five years ago i didn't really
recognize this about myself and as i
look at it now it's interesting i can
try traced it all the way to elementary
school when two things were always true
i was almost always the smartest kid in
the class and i was always the shortest
kid in the class
and because i was smart i had arrogance
and because i was short i had an
insecurity and it's taken me a lifetime
to arrive at that understanding of
something that happened and formed in me
when i was eight years old now
i guess this is my mission because
that information is really useful to me
i wish it hadn't taken me a lifetime to
figure it out so if i can speak to
people who are practicing their creative
craft no matter what it is and say pay
attention to the roots of you
be aware of and super accepting of all
of the parts of you that make you who
you are
then you'll find that all of the
subsequent steps are easier
you're more efficient and you're less
filled with heartache and again these
things contribute to good practice if
you have good practice you can get
better outcomes so it's weird to say
because you talk about i want them to
love me i want them to hire me i want
the next gig i want the one after that i
want the i want the adulation i want the
validation but all of that stuff really
comes to us more effectively if we don't
look at it directly if we look at it
obliquely and say i'm just going to be
over here doing my job and if good
things happen to me that's great that's
actually a much more efficient process
to getting to those good things in my
estimation
how do you find balancing that
creativity and commerce though because
it is show
business
and what i'm finding is like
almost suffocating
like my pursuit of money it's where i'm
like how
you know it's not it's great to write
jokes and it's it's great to do
interviews and but it's like but georgia
power doesn't accept you know gratitude
you know so it's like how how have you
and your like just your career is
incredible and how long it's been how
many people you've helped when have you
found
like your biggest financial success what
do you
what do you kind of um
attribute to that or like when you're
able to make money being creative like
what is that balance there help me
obviously that's the goal making money
being creative we want to have have our
our finance our money aligned with our
creativity obviously so
my controlling idea since i was very
young in my profession is
never leave money lying on the table if
there's money to be made in exchange for
creativity even if it's not directly
related to what i think i want i'm going
to go for it because then i can get paid
and i can also learn i'll give you an
example while i was getting my sitcom
career off the ground i had the
opportunity to write back cover copy for
500 movies that were in the public
domain that were being
released on videotape not even dvd but
video and i thought well that seems like
it's going to be a boring and
repetitious job but it's going to pain
me to write words and because it's going
to pay me words it's better than
anything that doesn't pay me to write
words
in order to embrace that opportunity i
have to step aside from my fear because
in that moment i'm going to say this
doesn't look like a job that i'm capable
of doing or qualified to do
so i better figure out a way to go for
it and claim that i'm incapable and
qualified even if i don't feel it in my
heart because i know there's learning in
it i have faith in myself that if i get
the job i'm going to do a reasonably
good job and if i don't what's the worst
that can happen i get fired you know
so
um so don't leave money on the table and
don't fear bad outcomes this is the
other thing people look at my career and
they say
of all the crazy things i've done in
weird situations all over the world what
is the controlling idea the controlling
idea is i don't fear bad outcomes i will
take any opportunity that comes my way
even though i might feel might even know
it's going to be a catastrophic failure
because there's a paycheck and there's
learning involved and there's growth
involved and if the bad thing happens
and i don't do that great a job on it
it's not going to kill me i'm going to
learn and move on so
to your question how can i make it pay
be
be focused on looking for work
where your creativity and paychecks are
in line with one another that is where
your creativity can earn and then track
your fear because here's what will
happen you'll go into a circumstance and
somebody will say to you i'd like you to
write me some jokes
and your fear will say i would like to
ask for
fifty dollars a hundred dollars thousand
dollars whatever that number is but a
little voice inside your head will say
hang on don't ask for that because if
you ask for that they might laugh in
your face and if they laugh in your face
what they're really saying is you think
you're worth any money at all and you're
wrong and you're laughable and you're a
loser and i hate you and therefore you
have to hate yourself and all of this
kind of internal editing goes on and
what it keeps us from doing is asking
for
what we're worth
uh creative people as a class negotiate
against themselves all the time because
of their fear here's a strategy you can
use that's really reliable
think about the most obscenely large
number you can imagine asking for for
your work
then double it and ask for that and if
you do that you'll probably be in the
right ballpark because you negotiate
against yourself you consider yourself
to be worth less
so you put a lower value on your work
and that makes it easy for people to say
yes but not easy for you to earn a lot
you know
i might say to myself i think my work
jokes are worth a dollar each or five
dollars each instead i'm gonna ask for
two or ten and see what happens they
might negotiate me right back to where i
was but i'm negotiating against myself
if i'm letting my fear get between
myself and the client
yeah i like that mindset around
yes you may have always dreamt of being
a stand-up comedian but what are other
creative things you can do
with that skill set you have so it may
be writing freelance for like a blog or
something but hey you're still a writer
and it's still just using your creative
skills in multiple different ways
yeah yes absolutely and to that point
versatility is key man if you know how
to do a lot of different things with
your tools with your writing tools with
your comic tools
or even you expand it in music or art
anything else that gives you more
opportunities to pursue opportunity and
more chances of
of getting
you know success somewhere along the way
um
i had the experience five years ago six
years ago now of entering visual art for
the first time i'd never done it before
my right house was kind of broken and i
really felt like i needed to recharge my
batteries and what i experienced was
complete insecurity because i'd never
done art before but that insecurity was
really refreshing and illuminating to me
because i had nothing i knew nothing i
was like bob dylan you got nothing you
got nothing to lose
and uh
and and look what i have achieved you
might think this is a digital background
but it's actually a physical background
and it's actually my artwork oh and so
so i've i've gained some chops and added
to my repertoire and what does this mean
this means i can do sexy covers of my
own books this means i can do cover work
for other people if they reach out to me
this means i have more ways to spend my
creative mojo because i have made the
conscious decision not to be limited
a lot of people listening to us today
probably define themselves as stand-up
comics and that's great it's good to
have a strong sense of self but it might
also be that they're while they're
defining themselves as stand-up comics
they're also defining themselves as not
other things for instance i'm a stand-up
comic i'm not a comic storyteller that
is to say i don't write sitcom well
that's just a block of definition that
you've placed between yourself and your
creativity because tomorrow morning you
might walk up wake up and say to
yourself okay i recognize that i am not
currently a stand-up comic but i can
enter that practice i can get a book
maybe a book called
a little book of sitcom
and um
[Music]
sorry and parentheses and also don't be
afraid to feel okay about yourself i
mean look where i am right now i
launched a new book into a stand-up
community where i don't have a lot of
cred i am not a known performer thank
you oh i'll do the same thing oh yeah
um and that's linked in the chat retail
for people and and every but every time
i try to sell myself i feel
self-conscious but
if i don't try to sell myself
if all i do is write the books and don't
try to sell them then what is the point
the the one liner i've been using is at
that point i'm just masturbating
differently
so so you know
not so good
[Music]
oh born brandon in the little book of
sitcom too very nice
good all right do you do you think we
should go to some of these questions
that are in this yeah yeah and uh mike
marr he had he has to go to an uh open
mics but he wanted
me to read this that john vorhaus is the
hairless rick rubin guru of comedy
writing
um
and then he said you can place that
quote on the front cover of your next
book
thank you i appreciate that i on the on
the back cover of the comic toolbox
there's a quote from a female sitcom
writer and and the quote is um i
wouldn't want to sleep with him but i'd
certainly buy his book
no
i always i always thought that that got
me uh
a certain amount of cred in a certain
amount of sales
over time
yes so let's um let's see what um kind
of questions we have here's one from
stargate stargate121
who asks have you ever written a script
for a performer you didn't think was
talented
that's a great question we note this
week the passing of howard hessmann
and he was on a tv show called uh head
of the class that i wrote for
and it's
it's weird and sad to think that the
star of that show is now dead
and i'm still alive but who knows for
how long anyway there was one character
on the show i won't i won't say who it
was but he kept kind of hexturing me
saying write me more good lines
and i kind of would have but i was so
low in the power structure it really
didn't matter what i did
um
with that said i tried to let not let i
try not to let my emotion get in the way
of my work a writer's job is to make an
emotional bridge between himself or
herself and the target or the
destination so when i'm writing for
other people i try not to assign a value
judgment to how i think about them i am
more interested in the question of what
do they need
can i meet that need how can i serve
them
a thousand years ago i wrote stand up
comedy for a 12 year old girl i was an
adult i was 30 at the time something
like that and my first thought was well
i don't really know how to speak to the
experience of a 12 year old girl because
i've never been a 12 year old girl but i
was a 12 year old boy once i know what
teenage life is like so i looked for the
points of connection between my
emotional state and the emotional state
of the person i was writing for now
whether this is writing for a character
in a sitcom or writing for a stand-up
comic my goal figure out what's going on
inside their heart and head and then
articulate that for them
of what i just said the most important
part is detach from value judgments we
look at situations and we say this is a
good situation or a bad situation i like
that guy or i don't like that guy this
is a good job or a bad job and all of
this stuff just gets in the way of doing
the job so
whenever i encounter myself having this
emotional reaction i remind myself
that i needn't make a value judgment i
can simply evaluate objectively
and the place i try to arrive at in my
life in all of my endeavors is
this thing that i'm experiencing is not
a good thing it's not a bad thing it's
just the thing that's happening now
and that strategy is good for dealing
with problematic personalities it's also
good for dealing with setbacks in your
life because if you get rejected as you
will get rejected and it crushes you if
you can only interpret it as that was a
bad thing and now i feel sad one thing
that's going to happen for sure is
you're not going to want to get back out
there and do it again but you have to
get back out there and do it again or
your progress stops so if you say to
yourself okay that was an outcome
wasn't a good outcome wasn't a bad
outcome it was just another outcome what
can i gain from the experience how can i
learn what can i do better next time
that'll put me you put you put me put
all of us in a frame of mind where we
can operate effectively in our own
self-interest
yeah
yeah and that really ties into uh
robin's question about what are the most
important
things to look for when watching a set
where you bombed in order to improve
best
here's where it starts for me
ask yourself what your intention is
a lot of stand up comics you see them
you've been them a lot of stand-up
comics present their material to the
audience like this like it's a little
baby bird cupped in your hands
and you're saying to the audience here
are my precious fragile jokes please
love them please don't hate them please
don't kill them can you identify with
state of mind joel have you been there a
hundred percent
100 percent i was actually taking note
of that right now yeah
okay so what we're doing in that moment
is we're giving the audience
uh
authority
over our state of mind we're saying to
the audience i will feel good if you
approve of me and it will feel bad if
you disapprove of me
and that in and of itself is a big block
to success on stage because the audience
is very uncomfortable with that feeling
they don't want that power and when they
sense you giving it to them they become
kind of standoffish you end up getting
the opposite reaction you're putting
this pressure on me for yourself uh for
your sense of self for you feeling about
yourself i don't want that that's not
what i'm here for i'm just here to laugh
when we do that we're trying to justify
ourselves to the audience instead of
doing that instead of seeking to justify
yourself to the audience seek to define
yourself for the audience say to
yourself to the audience this is who i
am this is my perspective this is my
point of view these are my jokes you're
going to like some of them you're not
going to like others of them i'm kind of
invulnerable to whether you like them or
not
if you don't like them later on i'm
going to go back and ask myself why
didn't this joke didn't why didn't this
joke work
and then i'm going to examine the
technology of it for example i might say
well the joke didn't work because it was
crowded with stuff that didn't need to
be there and i'll circle back to that in
a second if i may but
you can't even make that judgment until
you step outside of this i need your
approval thing when you go on stage
invulnerable to or let's say transparent
to the audience's approval then you're
in a position where you can perform and
succeed if jokes still don't work then
like i said you you go into the
structure of them the technology of them
and really examine what's going on one
of those that i make in this book is
at the end of the day there are three
classes of material in a joke
there's setup there's punchline and
there's other stuff
and as you get good at this game you
realize if it's not set up and it's not
punchline it doesn't belong in the joke
and you can cut it out and the mere act
of cutting out this stuff which i call
chuffa
meaningless information it doesn't need
to be there the mere act of cutting up
the clutter will go a long way toward
helping the jokes land better simply
because they're more efficient now what
fights against this for a lot of people
is the sense i'm telling them about my
life and i can't tell them about my life
if i'm not
truthful about the experience itself
give you an example i went through back
surgery not too long ago and i tell a
lot of jokes about back surgery i have
no interest in explaining what the thing
was really like i only have interest in
finding where the jokes are and landing
the jokes
but somebody else might say i had back
surgery and if i don't tell them chapter
and verse really what happened in that
back surgery they're not being loyal to
reality
what you need to understand is the
audience doesn't care about reality they
care about authenticity and those are
two different things reality is where
you say this is what really happened and
sometimes you defend the presence of
material in your act on the basis of i
have to leave it in there because it
really happened well no you don't need
to leave it in there because it really
happened that's just you thinking that
you have to be loyal to the facts
audience doesn't care about the facts
they want the authenticity they want the
emotional resonance they want to know
why it matter i'll give you an example
from my back surgery turns out that when
they did this back surgery they went
through my stomach which took me by
surprise i didn't know they were going
to do this now the next thing i will
tell you is about a conversation that i
had with the doctor that never took
place because i made this up i said to
the doctor did you encounter any
problems with the surgery and he said
well
yeah we did run into more stomach muscle
than we thought we were going to and i'm
like yeah you did
yeah you did
so
i'm looking for an emotional
authenticity about my sense of self i'm
trying to feel like a robust young
person and i got a joke that works for
that i have a structure for the joke
that involves a conversation that
doesn't actually happen that way
and that's quite right so detaching from
the need to portray reality
with
loyalty with fealty with uh authenticity
now that's not the right word but but to
make sure you get the facts right if you
let go of that then you can start to let
go of all the stuff that's only there to
support the facts and doesn't support
either the setup or the punch line
now these two things go hand in hand i
need to have acceptance and awareness if
i have acceptance and awareness then i
can look at a joke that i've written
without assigning a value judgment to it
without saying that's a i did a bad job
of writing that show
instead i can look at it objectively and
say which part is the setup this part
here which part is the punch line this
part here are they in the right order is
the setup before the punch line is the
key word or the funny word at the end
all of that stuff i can can ask
effectively because i'm out of the way
of my own emotion now and then this
other stuff here i love it i love it
because i wrote it you know every word i
write is a cherished child some of those
words have to die sometimes the whole
joke has to die or the whole set has to
die the more emotional clarity i have
the more acceptance and awareness they
have as a creator the easier all those
other things become
that's what i preach brother
yeah i definitely agree with like
looking at it objectively and not having
an emotional connection to you bombing
and taking it personally but looking at
it as an opportunity for growth and to
learn from well what did work what did i
do well and then if it didn't go well
what could i do to improve on that
instead of beating myself up about oh i
bombed i'm dumb
it's more of like oh cool you got on
stage and now you have all this
information that you can start to learn
from
ouch my feelings that's the controlling
idea for so many people
whatever happens it's ouch my feelings
and i just try and step outside that um
you're you're you're gonna bomb you're
gonna bomb spectacularly in fact for
years and years as a teacher of
creativity i have preached the idea if
you must fail and you will fail fail big
because then you have the sensation of a
spectacular failure and that's going to
feel good on some whole other level
you know it's it's funny because
uh some people have asked me about this
book well i've read the comic toolbox or
a little book sitcom or uh comedy
writing for life is there anything
really new in this book and
you should know people should know that
one thing i'm afraid of is belaboring
points i've already made i don't want to
be someone who packs new wine and old
old wine and new bottles as the saying
goes so something like fail big that's
an important principle but you won't
find it specifically in a little book of
stand-up because i've covered it in
other books and i don't like to cover
the same ground from book to book or
maybe i'm just trying to create a
a pipeline and by pipeline i mean
intravenous drug drip do all of my work
oh i will say this book is a main line
of information there's no fluff it
really is just to the point concisely
and very eloquently so even someone 12
years in i really learned a lot and it
was even some of it was even good
reminders of like oh man yeah i kind of
got away from thinking at my jokes
through this angle so it's like yeah
super valuable for any level
uh how do you find it so yeah for sure
sorry i was just going to say i
i feature i like to write small books
now it's not that i'm lazy or don't have
a lot to say but it's clear to me that
that's where the market is it's clear to
me that people don't have chin spans
that they had before cell phones came
around and there are other things
competing for our attention and i am
really committed in this in this stage
of my own writing life to being as
efficient with information as possible
so i at a certain point in the past i
think i would have been self-conscious
about writing a small book because it
would seem like i was lazy or not trying
hard or not delivering enough content
but
my experience has taught me that from a
marketing view from a helpfulness point
of view
information that's targeted and useful
that you can put to work now today to
improve your process that's what gets
the job done yeah you know it's like i
said before it's it's either setup or
punchline or something else likewise
with me it's either tools or inspiration
or awareness or something else and if
it's something else it doesn't really
need to be there
exactly yeah and i appreciate that and
it's now it's easy this is this is a
book that you can like reference
multiple times like i have other comedy
books but they're so much longer it's
kind of like i don't even kind of know
where to begin but like this is a book
that you can like travel with and just
use as like a point of reference
throughout your career
that it isn't like just the thing that
you like read and we're like all right
check that off my list of books i'm
supposed to read like i feel like this
is one a tool if you will yes
if you will and i certainly will
cause i've built my reputation on tools
exactly so uh let's see marcus mauser
says my problem right now is having
anxiety energy while i perform and feel
like my material is good
i just critique
i just
my critique to myself
is that wait
and how long did it take you wait
my problem is having like anxiety energy
while i perform and i feel like my
material is good and everything like
that
just my criticism i create to myself is
that is that critique i'm i'm i'm too
hard on myself i think is what he's is i
think that i think that's why if marcus
if that's not what you're saying um
forgive me for changing your question
into one i can answer because the answer
is simple don't be so hard on yourself
but but beyond that that simple um
answer is is one
that i think will work a little bit
better a lot of stand-up comics at a
certain point in their evolution simply
aren't getting in enough reps they're
not on stage enough
to reach the point where individual
performances don't matter if you're
going up 10 times a week and you bomb
once or twice or six times in the week
it's gonna wash off you because you've
got so many outcomes you start to
understand that no one outcome can
control your ego no one outcome can
define your state of mind it's not a
good thing it's not a bad thing it's
just another outcome i've had plenty of
those good and bad i'm gonna have plenty
more good and bad
i just need to put more energy into this
build more experience put in my work put
in my reps so that the things that i'm
feeling now will be replaced by other
things that i'm feeling later like why
the hell am i on the road and what the
hell can i do to get off the road as an
example
i once described my business model as
traveling great business to collect
paychecks and come home
and uh in the early days that was like i
was in i was in new england i was
performing as the strolling punk folk
troubadour i had a comedy music act and
i would go from what words i know i know
i'd grow out my beard and then shave
half of it and i wore a costume that was
half punk half folk it was nonsense but
it was fun
and and you know and i drive from boston
where i lived halfway across the state
and do a long-time strolling gig in the
college cafeteria and maybe a
songwriting workshop and then a thing in
a coffee house in the evening and take
my 200 paycheck and go home and that was
kind of the rhythm of my life later
after uh i published the comic toolbox
and it started to lay beautiful gifts at
my feet
people in other parts of the world
started reaching out to me and said can
you come here and teach this stuff to me
and then i started going much greater
distances and collecting much bigger
paychecks and at that point i realized
that my business model was this exactly
i'm traveling the world exchanging
information for experience and money
and if you had asked me when i was eight
years or ten years old would you be
happy with that outcome i would have
said yeah that sounds great are you
kidding i'm flying at other people's
expense i'm staying in hotels at other
people's expense they're paying me to
jabber at them until i'm blue in the
face that sounds like a party with
candles and cake for me how do i get
there get out of the way of my fear
represent myself to the world as someone
who can do the thing that i want to do
and then if somebody says okay prove it
somehow or another managed to find a way
to prove it
yeah yeah it so it you started getting
bigger opportunities when you saw
yourself worthy of them
yeah
no funny
i'm going to tell you it's exactly the
opposite but let me explain why
in
1993 or 1994 i was in australia
uh teaching at the australian film
television and radio school in the
company of some very heavy hitter sitcom
writers i might had teaching expertise
but these guys were stars of the game
and
i was i was still
kind of
caught up in this
um i'm not good enough uh
i'm not valid insecurity that was
prominent in my life at that time
during a break
after one of the presentations three
people came up to me as a as a group and
they said we want you to know that of
all the presenters we've seen today we
like you best and in that moment i heard
the following words come out of my mouth
and these words changed my life because
what i heard myself saying was exactly
this i'm not worthy
i appreciate your praise i value it i
cherish it but in this moment with the
force of revelation i realize i'm just
operating as as a kin of higher powers
not god higher powers but just i have
some capability and i seem to be
demonstrating this capability and so i'm
i i thank you for saying that but i'm
also profoundly aware of the gifts with
which i am operating and in that moment
i went from this is the key from fearing
i was not worthy to knowing is not
worthy and that's a big deal because if
you feel if you fear you're not worthy
then you're always afraid that someone's
going to find out you're a fraud or a
phony what i call in the comic toolbox
the fraud police fraud police are gonna
bust down the door and say you're you're
incapable of doing what you're doing
come with us quietly and nobody will get
hurt and it's the fraud police when you
know you're not worthy and you do
something that works out for yourself or
other people and you can appreciate that
it's because you stand on a platform of
practice expertise genetic gifts the
gift of life itself you're suddenly much
more at ease about it you don't have to
worry about people finding out you're a
phony because in some sense we're all
phonies we're all playing with the
house's money from the moment we're born
and when we have that idea alive in our
heads it it frees us up to take chances
much more easily and more fearlessly and
that's just that's a more effective
place to be especially if you're doing
something hard like stand up
so it like takes the pressure off of
like
thinking oh i'm worthy i'm great so now
you have these expectations and almost
obligations to fulfill
as opposed to
right yeah you're no you're you're on
you're on you're on something you're
onto strong medicine there because when
you're speaking when you're speaking of
expectations you're speaking of i'm
going to set the bar up here and then
because the bar is so high my pressure
is up here and with high pressure comes
low performance you just can't perform
well how do you increase performance you
lower pressure
so instead of going up on stage saying
i'm going to kill i'm going to impress
the booker in the back of the room i'm
going to make my future today right now
with all the burden of expectation that
carries you just go up on stage saying
i'm gonna have fun and do my best
because you know you can always have fun
you can always try to do your best that
that means that you've an expectation
you can easily exceed
rather than setting an expectation that
you most likely won't meet
and if that sounds like you're tricking
yourself you're playing a trick on
yourself in your mind you very much are
but the value of the trick is you
perform better and i mean perform both
in the sense of performing on stage as a
performer and just performing better
with your creativity performing more
efficiently in life
i mean it's going on a date you know you
go on a date i haven't been on a date in
a lifetime thanks to my wife she won't
let me date i don't know why
but but but i can imagine that if i were
dating now i feel a lot of pressure you
know like this date's got to work out or
i'm going to be sad and lonely for the
rest of my life that's a lot of pressure
i'm much better off going into that date
saying i'm going to try and have fun
have a good time in the moment see what
happens next that's low pressure when
you put yourself in a low pressure
environment you will always perform
better
and you can do it just by stating it my
goal is to have fun
i can't tell you how many situations
i've been in where i've said that to
myself going into it just have fun
i'm lying
but it's useful fiction
that i tell
myself as i point out in the book a
useful fiction is a fiction but it's
useful just the same the lies that we
tell ourselves can be very very
different
um what else we got yeah we got born
branded asking um
jv helped to create a documentary titled
misery loves comedy how do these
of his thesis oh oh
how do the yeah of his stand-up book
how do they do these
yeah
how did
yes we understand the question and born
brandon thank you for using the word
theses these so in such a sophisticated
fashion for a loop
these these thesises
the the controlling idea of that movie
it asks the question do you have to be
screwed up to do stand up or to stand up
screw you up and the punch line to the
joke is spoiler alert yes
but the comics who who are interviewed
in the in the documentary
speak of their inner life they speak of
with frankness
about what they experience what got them
into it what hurdles or setbacks they've
encountered what demons they've
confronted and
as a class they demonstrate
self-awareness
and it's funny you asked that question i
hadn't really thought about it
in that way because when i did the
documentary it was years and years
before i thought about writing this book
and i hadn't really put those two things
together but i would imagine if i went
back and looked at it now i would say
yeah what i'm seeing here is people who
know themselves
because they've taken the time to figure
out themselves and insofar as these are
people who we admire because they have a
level of success
we can see that yeah they put in hard
work yeah they have talent
and yeah they write good jokes they have
cleverness they've got lucky breaks you
know paulie shore is mitzi shore's
son so that's a leg up for him
but
the common denominator what else they
all have is a willingness to confront
themselves
and not be satisfied with work that's
only okay
and keep reinventing themselves and keep
reimagining themselves and leveling up
the quality of their material
something else i talk about in the book
and it's worth talking about
you got you've seen comics like this
they have five minutes and you know it's
their five minutes because you've heard
it for years can you think about comics
you know joel who are telling you the
same five minutes they told you last
year and the year before and the year
before that and you know what's what
they say in alcoholics anonymous the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different outcome you put those five
minutes before audience after audience
and you expect it to be
a transformational experience you expect
those jokes to do something different
than they did last time or the time
before
and if and if it doesn't happen you
blame the audience and you end up hating
and resenting the audience for not
having a uh an understanding of reality
that matches your understanding of
reality
one thing i've learned in my experience
is that reality doesn't care about my
expectations it's going to be what it is
flights are going to get canceled jobs
are going to get lost
people are going to die bad things are
going to happen whether i want them to
or not and whether i expect them to and
whether i'm happy about that so
for somebody who's holding on to their
first five minutes
trying to make it work even though
evidence exists that it's not working as
well as they want it to that's the time
to gently set it aside and take a fresh
pass
and
all you have to overcome at the moment
is the sense that the next five minutes
won't be as good as the last five
minutes but that's never going to be the
case the next five minutes will always
be better because they always stand on
the platform of the experience that have
gotten has gotten you as far as it's
gotten you so far
the people who don't get past that who
get locked into the five minutes and do
it at the same open mics week after week
month after month year after year it's
the self-awareness that they're lacking
they don't see themselves on a path
toward growth and by growth i mean
growth of self-awareness and as a
consequence they don't allow themselves
to undergo the necessary change that
will bring them to a higher level of
development
it's funny how it all comes back to the
same stuff self-awareness
self-acceptance you got those two things
you got everything you need
which is all mental
this is like it's ourselves though we'll
hold ourselves back
what else would it be
let's say i'm trying to write a joke
and
my first thought is here's a funny joke
situation let me explore it and then my
next thought is i'm not any good it's
probably not going to work i'm going to
come up with a joke that's bad and
people are going to hate me at that
moment my creativity slips because i'm
not thinking about solving the problem
of the joke i'm thinking about the
emotional reaction i will have to a
response that i can't
really anticipate because i haven't even
joked yet
how do i solve that problem by stepping
outside the vicious circle i'm caught in
the vicious circle that says you don't
achieve therefore you're no good
therefore you won't try therefore you
don't achieve
instead you can achieve therefore you
try therefore you get better therefore
you achieve more and that's what that's
what puts you in a vicious a virtuous
circle rather than a vicious circle
virtuous versus vicious yes
so
could you tell tell the uh the hot
breath the verse like where
where they can get the book and like
reach out to you because i mean even at
the at the end of the book you had such
a heartfelt
it's like letter to the reader that like
was very genuine sincere about how i
mean how much you like to help people as
well so um
yeah please tell us like where they can
get the book and yeah all that yeah
yeah um if you know the spelling of my
name john warehouse then you have key
pieces of information
you know how to find me on amazon
because you can go to my amazon author
page
which you can find just by googling john
vorks or googling little book of standup
that'll take you to amazon all of my
works are available most of my works are
available on amazon that's really the
only place i work online my thinking is
if you can't find your way to amazon you
can't find your way to anywhere so i
make my stuff available on amazon but
also on my own website which
coincidentally is johnvorehouse.com so
again if you have my name you have it
all on on my website you can download
pdfs of my books and you can get signed
printed copies that i can fulfill as
you've seen joel i i uh i write i sign
it i put it in an envelope i walk it to
the post office i send it to you and i
feel like the king of the world every
time i do that it was awesome and then
there you go and then and then the
further thing is there's a joke i used
to tell about myself
like i was i would be in some far-flung
part of the world blowing people's minds
with what i knew about sitcom and people
would say things to me like thank you
this has been so helpful and the joke
that i would say is don't thank me i
defined myself through service and it
was a joke to me because i didn't see
myself as being in service i really
thought i was just a selfish bastard but
john wesley harding the folk singer has
a great song lyric he says your jokes
will become your reality and over time i
found i really did value
the impact that i was having on other
people's lives and i think i valued it
because i started to understand this is
my purpose this is my legacy this is how
i'm making a difference in the world i
have no expectation of being a uh star
of a sitcom as an example but i do have
the firm expectation of helping other
people do better what they want to do
well so i am legitimately in service now
here's the thing if i'm legitimately in
service then i gotta walk it like a
talket and the way i do it is with my
famous jv five minute promise and here
it comes you're listening you're hearing
it now you said it in the book
if you think that i'm the sort of person
who can answer a question you might have
or solve a problem that you might have
related to your creativity or your
comedy or your dating life or your
personal habits or whatever if you think
i can help you reach out to me go to my
website click on the contact send me an
email here's my promise to you
gentle friend i will help you in any way
i can to the limit of my ability so long
as it doesn't take more than five
minutes and i don't have to leave my
desk because it turns out there's a hell
of a lot i can accomplish in five
minutes sitting at my desk and that's an
open promise to you it's one that i've
fulfilled for countless people
throughout my life and while it's a
benefit to you it's a tremendous benefit
to me because that means you're at my
website you're thinking about my work
maybe you're buying my books or maybe
you're just allowing my ideas to enter
your life and your mind where i think
they can do you some good so my door is
an open door and that is sincere and
genuine
awesome plus buy my books all my books
and my art
his email is in the book everyone so get
the book you can get his email for that
five minute promise
[Laughter]
thank you so much for sharing your time
way more than five minutes but thank you
so much it's good to have you back on
the show john and thank you for your
service and help here today
my my pleasure joel it's a pleasure to
spend time with you i see eagerly sees
every opportunity
because you're in service too majorly in
service and and and
maybe i i hope that knowing what what
you're dealing with with george water
and power
maybe you can can extract from this
session uh a little understanding that
the path that you're on in service to
other comics is not just kind of by
default where you ended up but probably
you belong and where you should stay
if i can close on this thought
the best place to be in life is at the
intersection of passion and purpose
where passion is the stuff that you're
good at and enjoy doing and purpose is
the stuff that you do because you know
it makes a difference obviously i'm at
the intersection of passion and purpose
when i'm writing books because i'm good
at that and i'm serving the purpose of
helping writers and that makes me feel
like my life is worthwhile so for you
for anybody listening ask yourself what
exists at the intersection of my passion
and purpose and try and work in that
space i think you'll be happy there
well go forth hop breath the verse find
the intersection of passion and purpose
and we'll see ya next monday
bye y'all sports team
woo